For more information, please visit www.youtube.com and www.facebook.com.
For more information, please visit www.facebook.com.
Hey Stacey, aren't you supposed to be at work today at the Bogey Club?
... about her music. All she listens to is that stupid karaoke thing.
Are you talking about Alma?
Hello, Alma. Don't you like hers?
Somebody took me.
Yeah, you'd rather listen to Stacey's music than, uh...
And mine is...
I need to man you guys up to take care of this place, because I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
That was amazing.
Huh. Nice work today.
Keep sleeping, Co-Rock. That won't bother you.
I'm talking to Co-Rock.
He wants to respect folks in the city.
Both with his wealth and wise.
I'm texting.
He's hyper when he's muted.
Okay, enough.
You parents out there, this we're gonna have to go through.
It's not fun.
I had to stick through it with my whole life, because I live for an eternity.
You're just gonna.
I don't think I'll ever will.
And what's your point?
That.
I can't live through this, and I have to.
Amanda.
Now you got Alma's name wrong.
It's actually just Stacy.
Now, Co-Rock, your case is finished.
There.
I'll turn the music down.
The Tollwook, Taraga, and the Bo-Rock are all the same.
They like going to sleep a lot, or just adventuring through their rooms.
And I'm going to put the music on.
Are you ready now?
Yes, I am, Alma.
Okay.
That's, Alma, the Tower of Bo-Rock.
Hey, it's not complete.
What?
You shouldn't bring them for a walk in the park.
Because remember the Turbo Crisis?
Parking.
Good luck.
Later.
You bring the kids.
Going later, actually.
They'll just drive.
Drive them back to their little spot.
Want to go in the training room with me?
What training room?
Uh, can you try not to whip me in pieces, because I'm going to be flipping around.
It's like it's possible.
I know.
Bias has arrived.
You have a huge sword, too heavy.
Right now, it's about the only attack it can do with it.
And the oldest sword in the history to see what the defense play.
Huh?
Okay.
I try to hit you with my sword, but then you duck out of the way.
That's the last time I hit a light in the training room.
Put that light out.
So much for the energy pills.
A lot.
They're the ones that suck.
You know my butt?
I'm surprised it didn't fling.
They usually fling when something hard hits them instead of explode.
Back in?
Okay.
Ready to leave?
Aren't you supposed to be making dinner?
Or somebody to do it with.
Your mother?
Fakes like next week.
Before dinner, can I go out?
Well, Stacy's are here.
Stacy's here.
Kids.
Can me and Stacy after dinner go out and get a new CD?
Sure.
And get a CD.
I don't really care.
Maybe some buffalo wings?
Nothing like some good October ale right before bed.
All right.
Our big brothers and big sisters and other big brothers and big sisters.
And little brothers and big sisters.
Come on.
It's a messy bed.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
This bed's a mess.
I'll drop my October ale right on Baby Sam's head.
Wonder if that's going to wake him up.
Maybe I'll give him my desk.
I think it's just a mechanical one.
I woke up before you got a mechanical one.
I gotta go hurry to the loogie's.
Blue, Blue, stop it or you won't get a treat this morning.
Family's breakfast!
I am taking a strict to him.
He wants to help me cook this morning.
You can take a rest this morning.
Don't you usually take a breakfast?
We sold it last year, remember?
Constance did it.
What do you want to make this morning?
She's way ahead of me this morning.
Get it out of the Unlimiter so we can have more time to hang out.
I'll get it.
The Unlimiter machine, not the Unlimiter.
The Unlimiter, uh, is huge.
If it made pie, it wouldn't be that expensive.
Yep, that's all it is.
We ran out of pie.
Yeah, Baby Constance threw it away last week.
I thought the smuggler stole it.
Oh yeah, Baby Constance.
Get some scrambled eggs.
Sure, I'll scramble them.
No, right now get your hands ready so you can scramble them.
On the...
Look at the new egg.
Three peanut butter cups in one.
I wonder if that...
Just put one to see what it tastes like.
Oh well.
Hershey's syrup for the pie.
I just put it on half of the pie.
Hershey's syrup.
That is Hershey's crunches of syrup.
Would you like some, um...
Would you like a muffin?
Classic caramel su...
Classic caramel sundae syrup is good.
Close your eyes.
It's my approval.
Hey, I sound like I was just on a commercial.
You were just on a commercial last week.
Oh.
I'm falling asleep.
Why is mom waking up?
I think it's Mother's Day today, isn't it?
Yes, it is, isn't it?
What?
Cranberry pie.
And the muffin has all the toppings on it.
Bring this up to now.
Wait a minute.
Do you think she wants to burn her tongue?
On Mother's Day? No.
So you should let it cool.
Hey, could you faster stick it in the freezer for about five seconds?
No, I can do it even faster.
Okay, you should let blossom do that.
No, she'll freeze it for that.
Oh yeah.
Mine's more...
Cooler.
Hers is more of a freezer.
Yeah, hers is more for like if you're overheating.
Yeah.
Clothing is burning out better.
Well, that's what's for stuff I can do.
It's gonna block out
our voices so we'll have to say
more than one time what
we're saying.
What do you say when you say,
you're too high?
You don't have to lose your score.
What?
Guys, you have a day off today.
Now you guys clean up this mess.
We're just fine doing what we like.
And we're saying the same thing.
We don't skip school today.
We have a substitute anyway.
Out with my notes.
Unlike that normal school out of the AC.
You're only allowed to skip two
schools a day throughout the year.
Then you're supposed to be important
so you can't waste them.
You can't use them during the time
you don't want to go.
Like if it's an all day assembly about something
that you don't like.
Who wants to stay out?
Gotta pick a cue.
Make sense about how you hate
pizza for your breakfast.
You usually own a desk.
So you have to do things early
so you don't have to rest in here
later in the day.
I think you better
put her
gloves near her
bank.
Take her gloves away
because you're gonna want to clean right away.
Because we got her a new pair of gloves.
No!
Come on.
Sure.
What's it about?
When's Stacy back?
She's upstairs.
I am her mommy now.
Tigger and Piglet went on a vacation.
Remember that?
Morning Dr. Senior.
What do you want to do this morning?
I don't know.
Maybe just hang out
and start climbing and all that.
Well you can't go
around yet because
because the kids aren't up
and they get
grouchy if they're woken up early.
That's what I meant.
Yeah they were sent for their
nap remember?
Oh yeah.
Good job Stacy.
Just come down and you can
hang out.
Mom's person.
Hey Stacy.
What's cooking for lunch?
Cheeseburgers.
Yeah the kids will be happier about that.
Yeah because you usually always have pigs.
I think he went to.
No he's helping Pepper deliver pizzas.
Pepper?
Oh yeah.
Yeah that's right.
Remember he was packing up the pizzas last night?
Yeah.
Quiet in the afternoon here.
Yeah it is.
Quiet.
Much to vary.
I think we got it now.
Yeah but what's going to be the goals?
This will be the goal.
I think last time we used the basket.
Yep that's the strawberry basket I used
last week for picking strawberries.
Okay.
It's going to be the goal
for the other guys.
What do you guys want it to be?
If it goes in there then I think
it makes a goal.
It's actually right there.
Song goes she's still with the art contest.
Okay sure.
Don't feel part.
I'll be over here.
Doctor senior can we like go back in our cases
it's much too loud.
Sure.
Because you just got out.
The translator I know.
Man I slept in it's lunch time already.
What's cooking for breakfast?
I mean lunch.
Oh well.
Cheeseburger.
Do you want to test your skills against it?
Sure.
Without your attacks on me.
I've got an idea.
We'll play soccer except Makuta's trying to
attack the soccer field.
And then everybody has to try
to play a normal soccer game
while Layla tries to keep him away.
Okay that sounds fun.
As long as he doesn't
a ma
Never do it.
You don't want a junkie.
He really talks too.
Big mouth.
Don't make fun of him.
Rig it. Rig it out.
Never mind.
Ouch my arm.
I will beat you Pa Rock.
Let's battle him.
You take the middle I'll take the front.
We can both beat him.
Hey Blossom.
You just wait in your case.
Blossom help me.
Sure.
Boys have to quit.
Make it fair.
You like that um
You like that um robot don't you?
General will fit.
It's the only kind we got.
I think Makuta will be very scared of you.
Now let's go.
Coming back. Huh?
When's Louie coming back?
A bunny's a fag.
He's been thinking that he is paper.
A swan. I remember that from one of his presentations.
You guys deal with your.
He lost something.
Sun stripe we gotta fix.
And don't be screaming.
Very dangerous.
I think it's about time to put him away.
You'll get to play.
Walk to me.
Who's cooking dinner tonight?
Me.
Because every night.
Because you're the best Belle.
But Belle is actually the best.
Isn't Belle training you?
Story.
So I don't really need training.
Did she tell you how easy it is to make up a story?
Take off what you're playing with.
Come down to the kindergarten.
I'm going to make lunch, okay?
Since nobody's actually making it.
Okay.
My volunteer is here.
And you helped to tell me what this is.
There was a little dog.
Who lived on a farm.
Snuck out in the night.
Always ran around.
They were always tired.
I want lunch.
And the creatures that she was.
Some were pink.
Some were green.
Something very nice to the old.
And it shrunk.
Then she took the rest of it.
Put it in her hand.
And held it there.
Time out.
You guys didn't know that.
And then she took a little ripe old table.
One day.
And stared at the baby.
Because she had a pink orange ribbon.
And a pink ribbon.
Amazing.
She was the richest horse in the world.
Right.
She took.
Dinner time.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go eat.
You're going to have to go get it.
Okay, when's it going to end?
One ribbon and a saddle.
Okay, go.
The next bought a ribbon instead of two.
The brown horse had a ribbon in the front.
And then.
The old old woman.
Was rooting through her old.
Looking.
For the blue ribbon.
She would look for anything.
To put on the next one.
She did not want that one.
Left out.
Find she should do.
She should take all the saddles away.
And just let them have a ribbon.
Suck onto their fur.
She took everything off pink ribbon.
On the big one.
She was very happy.
With all of her horses.
Ribbons.
But she found out.
She snitched the baby's saddle.
With the one that didn't have a saddle.
Because babies aren't allowed to have.
Ribbons off the horse.
A green one.
On the medium one.
Blue ribbon on the little one.
On the big one.
The medium one.
Would make one of the horses.
Look better than the other.
Story for the kids.
Sure.
Just shove them over.
I don't really care.
Kids don't listen to what I say.
I know.
You and your bath suits guys.
And this is the boy's dresser.
Now where's the shampoo?
You're going to need to be over here when you dress the boys.
Get off on this towel.
Shampoo.
Where's the shampoo?
I already put it in.
You know most of these guys are going to have to soak in it.
Why?
Because they're all fur.
Okay.
Because there's too many people I know.
Everybody out.
Okay, you tell them off.
I'll comb them.
Boys and comb them.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're telling them off. I'm combing them off.
Here's two combs.
Okay.
I need the big comb for this.
The next ones are over here.
Now you guys just need this one.
Patience.
Why is the soap soaking in there?
I need to brush you all under the stomach.
Everyone.
Your tail especially needs brushed.
Brushed.
No, you can't go to bed at this time.
Still, we've got plenty of time before bed.
It's only 7 o'clock in the afternoon.
About three hours,
hours before going to bed.
Matimeo, watch that,
watch that whisker.
Make sure they don't get clipped.
Vet?
Yeah, sometimes they don't accept us.
Is anybody hiding?
It's finished.
Better get them to bed.
You guys are going to bed early.
So if you're going to bed, I'm going to bed.
You clean up that stuff.
I'll get these guys.
Okay.
We're getting here.
We'll get them to you while you're in bed.
Yeah.
Turn the TV on for you guys.
Huh?
I'll turn the TV on for you guys.
He sort of got a beat when he went to bed.
Turn this down.
Here you go guys.
See, we still get the same air
as everybody else does.
I can watch the kids.
Thanks, Aku Aku.
No, I'm going to stay
and watch TV with them.
Hypnotize me.
Okay, I'm going to
put the wires on back there.
Snack?
Man, it's night. Yeah.
I like this one. I love it.
Of course you do.
I'm going to go
get a drink.
Four o'clock in the morning.
Turn the lights on.
Last all night, Dad.
Okay, it's about to turn this off.
Morning.
I'm supposed to be getting breakfast.
Yes?
It's Louie, not Swan. I am back again.
Now I've got to practice my trumpet.
I'm going to practice my trumpet.
Oh, great.
You're going to make the kids hyper.
Can I have Yooka Call?
Yeah, every year.
It's silly to wake up the people
that have woken up.
I mean, it's silly to wake up
the people that haven't woken up.
It drives the kids crazy.
Because the old Louie's back.
And my little Ella. Where's my little Ella?
Do I blow the Yooka Call?
Now let me play.
Let me see you try to play the Yooka Call.
Now let me try.
Everybody up.
Sixty people running everywhere.
Kids, you're going back here.
Baby Ella, you're going to have to go back to bed.
Keep there.
Oh, it's off the lock.
He wants peace
and quiet.
Do you have that potion now?
Yeah, sure.
I'm going to go get that potion
from Bor, okay?
When's today Grandfather's Day?
I'm going to practice my sword skills.
Okay.
See my new sword?
Did you go to the training room?
No, that wasn't the sword I used before.
You didn't go with me.
Um, I think these three
are calling Bella.
Okay.
I'll go get her.
Oh, I don't want to cheer her up.
Remember to put these scallywags back to bed
when, um,
when Bella's finished playing with them.
Mommy.
On stands.
One, two, three.
Each of you get one.
I'll, um, play basketball.
We're going to get you guys in bed.
Join us next time
on The Super Family's Second Movie.
See you in the next video.
Yes.
Since you weren't in.
Now all pose.
All pose.
Smile.